they arrived in their hundreds taking
over some of the city's largest shopping
malls at the new town plaza in scharton
they converged on every floor shops
linked the mainland with a target this
time some stopped on China's national
flag before ripping it up through hours
they sang and yelled abuse at store
owners suspected of being Pro Beijing or
pro Hong Kong government eventually
stores and restaurants with Forster
clothes outside the mall protesters used
umbrellas to hide their faces before
smashing security cameras and burning
barricades specialist riot police then
moved in issued a warning and fired
several rounds of tear gas to disperse
the crowd at another wall in Kowloon
around 200 protesters marched through
the shopping centre chanting slogans
such as fight for freedom and revive
Hong Kong gatherings like this in
shopping malls are a new tactic being
used by protesters it's a peaceful means
of getting their message across at the
same time they're targeting Chinese
owned companies but the peace didn't
last long
police moved in after protesters
vandalized stores and a metro station
the crowd was chased out of the mall the
station closed despite the chaos caused
fewer demonstrators took part compared
to the previous 16 weeks of Sunday
protests Hong Kong's chief executive
Carrie Lam is due to host the first in a
series of public meetings which she
hopes will end the crisis that
protesters say they won't back down
until their demands for greater freedom
and lesser control from Beijing are met
Sarah Clark al-jazeera Hong Kong